okay uh
we're on overtime now
for max why haven't the russians
launched a cyber attack on the u.s yet
oh yeah that's a good question i thought
maybe that would happen after the
unpleasantness started with you well and
i thought that would be the way they
would get back at us you know people
would see their bank accounts
oh yeah no they're trying all the time
but you know we've had since 2014 we've
had a lot of time not just to get our
tech together but also to get our
doctrine together that's the most
important thing we have the tools now we
have the strategy you know he's been
fighting it's called fighting in the
gray zone and he's been fighting in the
gray zone for quite a while and we're
just starting to get better which may
explain why he rolled in the tanks when
he did
because they were a generation ahead of
us in asymmetric means but we have been
catching up oh good
so not to say they won't i mean that's i
mean this is something very important
everyone should back up their data if
you've got something in the cloud it's
not a cloud it is a data park somewhere
and it can be hacked and wiped out so if
you got something important put it on a
drive put the drive in a drawer
note to self yeah okay
uh
mr secretary how has russian's invasion
of ukraine affected a possible revival
of the iran nuclear deal where are we
with the iran nuclear deal we had it we
we get rid of it now we're trying to get
it back well uh russia was threatening
to undercut it
but seems to have backed off on that let
me say one thing bill which is not
recognized enough and that was in 2015
when the deal was cut
uh russia was the most helpful country
uh and the iran nuclear deal with the
iranian
exactly there were like six countries at
the table six countries at the table
plus iran so us uh
three europeans uk french germans right
russians chinese okay and um and why
were the russians the most helpful uh
because they stepped up
and allowed iran to come into compliance
they took all their crap uh back to
russia which was a great service that's
how they were helpful
why
why what was in it for them because they
don't do things just because they're
because all the countries there
including russia
really did not want iran to have a
nuclear weapon
it was in it was in nobody's interest
right now uh i think we will learn
within days
uh whether or not this deal will go down
let me say unequivocally it would be
good for us if it did come back
uh there's a lot of you know a lot of
white noise on this but i'll give you
two reasons
one is that we will go back to the most
important part of the agreement for a
long time
verification secondly
a very important part of the deal was
limiting iran to 300 kilograms of very
low enriched uranium that'll come back
for nine years
we've got to use the nine years better
than we used the last four years in
which we accomplished nothing with iran
and meaning use the nine years to get
iran to be a friendlier nation toward us
uh either friendlier or uh or use
unfriendly means but we've got to
address
the houthis for example what the houthis
in yemen uh that's the those are the
people the houthis yeah is that how you
pronounce that that's how i pronounce it
i don't know
well it would look like it was houthi
it's th houthi who you say
i say cookie is something i smoke out of
right
hookah smoking caterpillar right uh the
um right well for example
we gotta drag them into this the hook
you know oh lord because he's the reason
oh it doesn't have the reason
we want saudi arabia and the emirates to
help us
we've been asking them to make more
royal
you know they're kind of annoyed that
they get keep getting hit by rockets and
drones and we haven't done goddamn
anything okay so that's the reason watch
your language on my show
this is not a brother i forgot about
that i thought you were the aclu anyway
i'm kidding um do you think we're um
lumping the russians i mean too much
with their government i feel like in
this country what we're doing now
everything russian is bad and every
russian is bad and that might have first
of all it's not fair you know if if if
they weren't white i feel like we would
call that racism
you know i i to to lump everybody
together not every i mean a lot of the
russian people don't know what's going
on yeah i don't love any of these
stories you hear about you know a young
russian pianist being cancelled from his
performance with the montreal symphony
right because he's russian i mean there
are just there's there is a way that
this has gone way too far also
strategically it's unwise because what
we were very smart about doing in world
war ii is we knew the war was going to
come to an end and we knew that if we
punished all germans the way we did
after world war one we would back them
into a corner so we crafted the
narrative that you germans are led
astray by hitler because we knew even if
in some cases it wasn't true
you know we said to the average nazi you
still got to run the post office so we
have to think we cannot back the
russians as an entire group into a
corner if we can separate putin's from
the russians in general then we don't
only have a victory we have a post-war
plan
okay
i would just just add
that you know like nato and russia back
before 2014
we set in motion a new mechanism to talk
if there were crises
as soon as a crisis came we said we're
not going to talk makes no sense right
you talk about the red phone the famous
red phone no no no no i'm talking about
the nato russia uh
but at some point they did put in that
was it during kennedy that was that was
after the cuban uh right so they put in
the
hotline hotline so that like if the [ __ ]
goes down call me first right right
but this was nato yeah anyway and also i
mean i must say under trump
milly who was the chairman of the joint
chiefs assured the chinese yes that this
not who i work for
if he gives the order i'm not going to
do it
i would like to think that putin has
someone around him like that
we you know we have a big problem on the
scale of the iran nuclear deal because
what happened was ukraine was born
nuclear right it was born independent
with a soviet nuclear stockpile it only
agreed to give up those nuclear weapons
with the express promise that russia
would never invade and now they've done
it right and so basically what that says
to every small country in the world that
is not aligned the only way to protect
your survival is with an atom bomb so
the iran nuclear deal is just one of
many many nuclear deals we're going to
have to diffuse it's not even just like
non-aligned i mean australia in the last
couple of months has said you know what
i think it'd be good for us to be a
little bit more of a nuclear power that
they're even a country like them you who
you used to be able to say well they're
under the protection of the united
states it'll be fine even they're saying
we'd like to be in charge of our own
defense a little bit more and how many
times vietnam iraq with the kurds
afghanistan this instance you just
mentioned how many times can we do this
to countries say we'll be there
and then not be there before
well but this this is the big picture
this is what we need to talk about bill
this is a turning point in history with
this war this is the haley selassie
moment this is the moment when the
emperor of ethiopia went to the league
of nations in 1936 and begged them
highly to help us highly selassie
he begged them to stop this dictator
mussolini from invading his country
right and he said today is us tomorrow
is you and the world did nothing and
that gave the green light to another
dictator adolf hitler you know you've
got you've got a production assistant on
this show this kid his family is swedish
they're in sweden right now and they
know what the europeans know what we
don't seem to understand
is that if we don't stop putin now
he will keep going and i'm not saying we
get involved there is a line nato forces
must never under any circumstances fire
on russian forces that is the line but
if the ukrainians are willing to shed
their blood not just for themselves but
for the entire world
we owe it to our children to help them
because if we don't stop putin
then we
we condemn our children and our
grandchildren to another century of war
so
since you mr uh
since you're mr know-it-all
answer me this why do the rastafarians
worship haile selassie what is that all
about
i know a little bit about it tell me
okay
that is a religion that it is similar to
the ancient hebrews
that ethiopia is zion the caribbean is
babylon and they are a diaspora the
slaves brought to the caribbean as the
diaspora in babylon and someday they
will return to zion but where does the
pot come in
where does this
rastafarian
highly selassie and we never stop
smoking blunts all day
where
what is that
i i've always been confused about that
you got me there all right thank you
very much
[Applause]
you